muchas gracias
en el año 1971 comienza
está esta aventura
que el tiempo dirá si valió la pena
en el año
primero comentarles lo de la zona de
confort 1 cuando no está la panza de
mamá evidentemente está en una zona de
confort cuando nace pasa una zona de
aventura se acaba toda la seguridad y
esa zona aventura que vivir más vale
vivirla con la creatividad de compañera
que sin ella no es cierto en el año 1979
tomó la primera comunión y en la primera
comunión en los estudios lo que aprendí
respecto a la creatividad es que
estudiar de memoria no sirve para nada
porque estudiar de memoria lo que
provoca es un olvido seguro de lo que
uno estudia y en el olvido seguro hay
una imposibilidad creativa
y eso lo quiero relacionar con algo que
publique en alguno de los libros que es
el triángulo de la disrupción
uno para poder crear tiene que combinar
elementos y si no puede guardar
elementos en su memoria no puede
combinar absolutamente nada
cuanto más guarde su memoria cuanto más
cosas distintas guarda más puede
combinar por eso ustedes ven los dos los
puntitos rojos que están uno arriba del
otro yo digo que combinar agua conagua
desgraciadamente lo que produce es agua
cuanto más se alejan los puntos entre sí
para combinar es cuánto más disruptivo
puedo ser en el año 1988 un entrenador
creyó que yo podía jugar de
centrodelantero de número 9 y eso lo que
me enseñó es que a veces los seres
humanos tenemos ideas muy estúpidas
en el año 1992 comienzo mi tarea como
preparador físico de fútbol lo que hacía
era seguir todas las pretemporadas que
se hacían en necochea vélez-huracán en
fin todos los equipos que venían y yo lo
trasladaba a mis equipos de necochea
claro los entrenamientos eran buenos se
podría decir que eran buenos pero eran
los entrenamientos de otros luego en los
entrenamientos de germán castañón eran
nuestros entrenamientos el entrenador de
vélez de lo que ya le conté entonces ahí
un poco que también decido que tengo que
empezar a hacer lo mismo no es cierto en
el año 1994 me hago cargo de una colonia
de vacaciones y
pasamos a hacer un cambio importante en
esa colonia vacaciones nos reuníamos
todos los días viernes a hacer lo que se
llaman lluvia de ideas esto lo aprendí
más tarde que existían storming entonces
todos los viernes nos juntábamos con los
profesores y diagramamos las actividades
para la semana siguiente la obligación
era que no podíamos sacar una sola
actividad de los libros tenían que ser
absolutamente todas creadas por nosotros
entonces ahí lo que aprendí es que eso
el acto de crear provoca goce placer y a
la vez eleva la autoestima es muy
diferente a estar copiando y pegando
claro que tiene algunas dificultades
como hay que dedicarle tiempo también
hay que tener valentía para implementar
lo propio y no caer en una fórmula
segura y por supuesto hay que
experimentar para ver si eso va a
funcionar correctamente en el año 1999
me topo con este autor con edward de
bono que escribió una obra maestra que
llama el pensamiento lateral en el cual
pude de alguna forma certificar todo lo
que venía pensando estaba un poquito
cansado de escuchar sobre la
inteligencia tradicional sobre el
pensamiento lógico yo sentía que había
algo
y algo más me lo dio edward de bono en
el año 2004 decidió lanzarse a la
aventura de la creatividad como un
emprendedor como todo emprendedor de esa
época
lo primero que hacíamos era hacer un
sitio web y con eso creíamos que íbamos
a conquistar al mundo en el año 2005 se
produce el nacimiento de mi hija y en el
nacimiento de todo de un hijo es un
hecho disruptivo en la vida de las
personas con lo cual
decido que tenía que disminuir mi carga
laboral yo tenía siete trabajos y decidí
bajar casi a la mitad para tener más
tiempo para compartir con mi familia
para compartir con mi hija y para
dedicarme a ese emprendimiento que les
conté que inicie en el 2004 la carrera
como emprendedor en tema de creatividad
innovación
pero resulta que en el año 2006
habían pasado dos años y todavía no
tenía ni un solo cliente porque todos
los que creíamos que poníamos un sitio
web y todo el mundo nos iba a estar
viendo en realidad nadie te veía si no
buscabas alguna forma diferente de poder
llamar la atención piensen ustedes que
es una época en las cuales no había
redes sociales prácticamente no existían
entonces decidí crear una newsletter de
creatividad innovación aplicada a la
empresa una newsletter básicamente es
una revista digital que llega por correo
electrónico entonces pensaba y aquí ha
empezado a poner algunas estrategias
creativas de qué empresa quiero que me
lean
y entonces digo tengo que armar una base
porque a quién le voy a enviar ese
newsletter entonces buscaba cuál era el
patrón de un correo electrónico yo le
puse como ejemplo
jose punto pérez a necochea puntocom en
otras empresas eran j.pérez arroba
necochea puntocom en otra era sin el
punto entre medio etcétera de esa forma
eso después lo que hacía era buscaba
quien era el sello de esta empresa vamos
a suponer que se llamaba pedro garcía
entonces con el patrón que ya había
tratado de descubrir de cómo era la
empresa inventaba el correo electrónico
real y lo cargaba a mi base de datos
entonces yo podía de esa forma que
cualquier persona en el mundo pudiera
leer lo que yo estaba haciendo ya me
había creado mi propia mi propia
comunicación ahora bien también quería
comunicarme personalmente con esos
gerentes de empresas
y pensaba que tenía que hacerlo de
alguna forma original porque si me
dedicaba a la creatividad de la
innovación y mandaba un correo
electrónico común no iba a poder ser
entonces piensan ustedes que es un mail
lógico cuando mandamos un correo
electrónico es el título y el cuerpo del
título no es cierto y se envía pues yo
trataba de verlo por el otro lado que es
que sería un correo electrónico que no
es lógico que es ilógico
y en un momento se me ocurrió enviar
solamente con los títulos entonces ahí
les puse un ejemplo
esto era lo que le mandaba a los gerente
de las empresas el nivel vacío pero todo
el mensaje se iba encadenando en los
distintos los títulos del correo
electrónico entonces ahí hay uno que se
lo dije a mi hija que dice hola
felicitas cómo estás mi niña hermosa te
amo con locura hija mía fíjense que de
esa manera el que leía el correo
electrónico de la empresa no necesitaba
abrir el correo le invadía su correo
electrónico para llamar la atención y ya
que hablo de mi hija
le voy a dedicar este corazoncito que la
tengo acá te amo hija mía
seguimos cuál fue la conclusión de eso
la conclusión fue que uno no necesita
ideas gigantes para armarse su propia
revolución estamos hablando de una
revistita muy simple y estamos hablando
de cambiar lo que sería el formato
original de mandar un correo electrónico
con esas dos estrategias pequeñas con
esas dos ideas logre insertarse en el
mundo competitivo de la creatividad y la
innovación en el año 2007
en esa publicación había acertijo de
pensamiento lateral y le voy a proponer
que conteste en uno le voy a dar diez
segundos nada más
griten si quiere dos personas estuvieron
jugando a las damas de cinco partidas
cada uno ganó tres como es posible
como es posible
muy bien no estaban jugando entre sí
quién lo dijo un aplauso
ahora bien yo le conté que esa revista
hacía jugar a la gente y había aseos de
empresa armaba una tabla de posiciones y
había sido de empresas que estaban
fascinados con eso solamente porque les
armaba una tabla de posiciones y les
llegaba toda la semana pero qué pasa eso
me despertó otra idea que podía llegar a
crear algo personal entonces decido
crear los acertijos de pensamiento del
lateral de negocios una nueva categoría
para insertar me
tenía que convencer a alguien que me la
publicara aún a un editor pues qué pasa
se acuerdan cuando les conté que cargaba
los correos electrónicos yo ya había
cargado el correo electrónico de la
dueña de una editorial entonces le
escribo a la dueña de la de la editorial
que quería presentarle un libro pues
bien voy lo presento pero qué haría una
persona normal cuando quiere presentar
un libro presentaría un libro no es
cierto en realidad yo lo que hice me fui
con cinco sobres nos pusimos en la mesa
la invite a jugar de esa forma de esa
forma lúdica entretenida la mujer se vio
en cierta forma sorprendida vio que los
contenidos eran bastante originales y
decide que vale la pena publicar el
libro en el año 2008 se publica para
toda latinoamérica
ellos tienen base en méxico también el
libro el ideas beat caso de creatividad
e innovación en los negocios los invito
a jugar también con este dice una
importante compañía multinacional
decidió no oficial equipo de fútbol
baloncesto y otros deportes mundialmente
populares y optó por transformarse en el
principal patrocinador de un conjunto de
cricket porque
ustedes
por qué
les doy una pista fue una decisión
estratégica esto es el libro es en todos
presentes en el mercado se convirtió en
un caso de estudio tienen alguna
respuesta
hay que pensar lateralmente la respuesta
es que la decisión de pepsi de
patrocinar un equipo de cricket fue
tomada en el marco es estrategia para
consolidarse en pakistán donde es líder
en ventas ya que ese deporte es uno de
los favoritos del país claro uno cuando
lee el acertijo lo primero que hace es
pensar en su propio país
pensar lateralmente solamente me permite
pensar que no se trataba de argentina y
cerca mío en el año 2010 ya teníamos
prácticamente todo arreglado para salir
con un segundo libro dos o tres meses
antes me dicen que el libro no iba a
salir a la venta
lejos de quejarme lejos de ponerme una
posición negativa decidió contestar ese
correo electrónico y les envío 25
propuestas diferentes para que el libro
finalmente pudiera ser publicado me
dicen que lo van a analizar con el
comité editorial y alós
1520 días me llegó una contestación
donde dicen recapacitamos el libro lo
vamos a publicar tal cual estaba en el
formato original de ahí lo que aprendí
es que cuando uno piensa en 25
propuestas no de ahí lo que aprendí es
que uno cuando ofrece un abanico grande
de posibilidades hay muchas
posibilidades generar empatía con eso en
alguna la otra persona se va aprender
cuando uno ofrece una sola idea no le
gusta y se terminó hay verdad
en el 2011 entonces se publica el libro
gente positiva gente negativa para toda
latinoamérica pero en el 2011 también
asumo como funcionario municipal en el
área de innovación de la municipalidad
de necochea con algunos programas más o
menos exitosos como puede ser la feria
de emprendedores cómo pudo hacer mentes
creativas o las escuelas de niños
inventores que habíamos creado también
ocurría lo siguiente yo escuchaba mucho
la queja acerca de que necochea se había
quedado sin su postal que necochea se
había quedado sin su postal tiene coche
se quedó sin su postal entonces se me
ocurrió desarrollar un concepto que es
el reloj gigante inspirado en el cucu de
carro para que cada hora giraría y
vertería el contenido sería un reloj
gigante en la arena para la playa de
tierra en el parque el hilo de agua en
el río quequén y cada uno de esos
relojes estaría con una pequeña oficina
de turismo en el cual
y los turistas pudieran averiguar sobre
las experiencias que se pueden hacer
turísticamente en cada uno de esos
lugares
en definitiva el concepto es tres
relojes cien experiencias por supuesto
que eso no se pudo llevar adelante
porque ustedes saben cómo es la vida en
la función pública a veces es muy
cortita y en el año 2013 se terminó esa
aventura y rápidamente otra vez sin
quejas ni protestas ni nada decidido
continuar con mi camino y me pongo a
hacer el máster de innovación y
desarrollo emprendedor en el año 2014
entremedio decido ayudar en la
preparación de un boxeador y luego lo
entrenamos con distintas actividades
bastante fuera de lo tradicional boxear
contra dos a la vez golpear una bolsa
donde estaba la cara del oponente tenía
que estar buscando permanentemente cómo
pegarle al oponente le tiramos una
pelota y él tenía que boxear y
perceptivamente tenía que encontrar la
pelota y sacarla del ring hicimos
básicamente lo que hoy se habla mucho
como entrenamiento neurocientífico
preparamos a ese boxeador por arriba de
cómo se lo prepara en la media
en el año 2015 se publica el segundo
libro el pensamiento en montaña rusa que
básicamente es una concatenación de lo
anterior que cuando se rindió para tener
el titulado del máster en innovación el
contenido de ese máster fue a parar al
libro ahí lo que aprendí es que la
originalidad llama la atención pero no
siempre es tan buena sino facilita las
cosas al otro porque porque el libro fue
escrito
sin ningún capítulo es desde el
principio al fin y no hay capítulos
entonces la gente me decía que el libro
estaba bueno que el contenido estaba
bueno pero que le había dificultado
mucho el trabajo entonces la
originalidad muy bien pero tampoco
complicarle las cosas al cliente en el
año 2017 ocurre lo siguiente me viene
como un eureka a la cabeza yo desde el
año 92 ya era entrenador profesor desde
el año 2004 me estaba dedicando a los
temas de creatividad e innovación y
nunca había podido unir las dos
profesiones tardé muchísimos años en
darme cuenta que podía hacer algo
uniendo los dos caminos entonces decido
escribir averiguo no había ninguno en el
mundo abrigo en varios idiomas y decidió
escribir el primer libro de creatividad
innovación aplicada al fútbol este libro
es que es mi cuarto libro
también
me permitió comprender lo siguiente que
yo estaba compitiendo como consultor en
tema de creatividad e innovación en la
empresa con cientos y miles de
consultores y cuando me voy al otro
camino prácticamente estaba compitiendo
solo porque no había nadie en ese
escenario compitiendo entonces eso lo
que nos ayuda a entender es que uno
tiene que encontrar un nicho tiene que
encontrar un espacio un lugar donde se
pueda mover este de forma novedosa en el
año 2018 gracias a eso trabajo con un
entrenador de la liga profesional
japonesa y con él también hicimos unas
cuantas locuras tenía que levantarme a
ver los partidos de las 23 de la mañana
porque hay 12 horas de diferencia y asia
lo cubre hacemos algunas locuras como
por ejemplo parecidas a la que hicimos
con el boxeador jugábamos partidos los
titulares contra 16 suplentes entonces
si esos titulares podían jugar bien
contra los 16 suplentes evidentemente el
día domingo que competían para ellos iba
a ser mucho más fácil
en el año 2019 ahora lo que estoy
haciendo estoy asesorando un grupo
multimedios tv radio y diarios y lo
primero que la primera determinación que
tomé cuando empecé a trabajar con esa
empresa era que había que escuchar a la
gente las ideas de la gente a todos nos
gusta que nos escuchen ser tenidos en
cuenta entonces desarrollamos una
aplicación en el cual los empleados de
la empresa permanentemente están
buscando ideas a veces disruptivas a
veces no tanto para que esa empresa
mejore las organizaciones están llenas
de ideas porque están compuestas por
personas que a las personas les gusta
les gusta mucho crear
fíjense ahora el camino cómo corre o no
de copiar como preparador físico a
empezar a crear en la colonia de
vacaciones eso me llevó a emprender en
creatividad eso me llevó a producir la
newsletter eso me llevó a escribir los
libros y los libros me llevaron a la
asesoría y no hubo grandes ideas en el
medio no hubo genialidad es en el medio
hubo pequeñas ideas porque las pequeñas
ideas también valen para el futuro que
queda bueno voy a ver si puedo insertar
algunos juegos de mesa que creé en la
góndola de las jugueterías
he creado un método de preparación para
fútbol infantil que lo voy a ofrecer de
forma gratuita a través de mi sitio web
para todos aquellos entrenadores que son
papás y que necesitan formación quiero
hacer mi contribución y la quiero hacer
gratuita y muchas otras cosas más la
idea es seguir tirando me de palomitas a
la aventura creativa
[Música]
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]